find the number which if increased by 18
percent increased by 18 percent if you
do that then it gives 767 okay now the
reason why I chose to do this first
right before you get to that is because
an instinct is are well if you increase
by 18 percent of got that then maybe a
way to go back is by decreasing by 18
percent right because that's kind of
like the opposite but we just saw if you
do one thing and then you do its
opposite right with percentages it works
a little bit differently can you see why
by the way right when you took off this
10% it was a bigger amount so this 10
percent fool is bigger than this 10
percent okay so who else is just how
might we had to go this year okay so
what I have here right is my end result
now decreasing by 82 I want you to try
out you see what happens get your
calculator out see if that will work for
you now I'm going to just give you a bit
of a spoiler you've run into some
problems that you run through some
problems right so here's how I'm gonna
help you see it
when you try it and see what happens and
see if you get you can come back and see
for what okay how about look at this
this is the very first question we start
this morning right very first one I want
you to look at this as if this were the
question that we sign it but to be
different we're increasing now I'd
actually don't know what the starting
point is I don't know what this number
is okay
but I do increase it by how much 18 like
18 okay now this was the equation I
wrote before I'm going to change it
based on what I learned out and what the
question tells me this is not here what
is it don't know I don't know what is I
just put a question mark there right so
tonight okay
I changed his percentage used to be five
she gave me this so what should this be
now a hundred and eighteen a number was
increased by 18 percent and then I got
that he's the funny thing he's why it's
a bit backwards bro they giving us the
answer right the question says you
should get six seven hundred and
sixty-seven okay now you're like okay
fractions percentages this one masteries
I get this okay but this is actually
looking back to a topic we do last term
right there's a whole topic diverted to
when you're trying to work with the
number and you don't know what the
number is right itís called algebra
right
instead of putting a question mark we
give a letter there right just put a
letter any letter you like X is just
kind of a common one right and now we
can solve this thing I want to know what
the X is so in order to have X by itself
by itself right are you going to I need
to be an extra state I want this out of
the way I know it sounds like B's the
opposite
do you agree with this I've done the
same thing to both sides so everything's
all balanced and that kind of thing
I multiplied by this number and then I
divided by exactly the same number
does that make sense like if you have a
number you double it then you have it
you'll get back to the same thing okay
so that's what X should actually be this
will all disappear 700c service ohm
reach for their calculator and tell me
what happens when you divide by watch
out for the fraction divided by 118 over
a hundred six hundred and exactly you
know
okay now the great thing here is put
exactly I can test this out can't I okay
as if this was this question if 651 I
keep Queens honest I guess if 650 were
increased by 18 percent I beef multiply
it by a hundred eighteen over hundred
say go and check out does it give you
what we're supposed to get seven six
seven done okay